- Depending on what it
is, yes I like animals.
- Yeah, I love animals.
They're better than us.
- Bein' around 'em and
pettin' em if they're fuzzy.
- Dream pet list.
Dog, goat,
yak.
I mean, I'm almost 30,
I think anything more is
gonna put me in the crazy,
(laughs) the crazy bin.
(happy guitar music)
Whatever's in that cage is
big and loud, and it's moving,
and I'm a little freaked out by it.
- Sure.
- I'm ready to meet my buddy.
- Made a little noise.
- Is that a skunk?
(beep)
- Woah.
Oh my God.
- What?
- Oh ho ho, what?
Aww, hi.
- Hello, here's a leaf.
Oh, you wanna eat that leaf?
You don't wanna eat the
leaf I'm giving you?
It's pretty rude.
- This is the coolest thing
that's ever happened to me.
Oh, there's two!
There's a baby.
- My God, it's a baby!
Here you go, little baby.
- Two (gasps)?
Oh my--
- Oh!
Okay.
This is cool.
I'm good, I'm gonna stand.
- Oh, can I touch 'em?
- What's the touching situation
here, 'cause I feel like
it could go bad real quick (laughs).
- Oh.
- These are so cool.
(laughs)
- Oop, oop, it got me.
It didn't hurt at all,
it just was like eh.
- I thought it was a skunk at first,
'cause of the black and white.
It's a porcupine (laughs).
- I know it's probably very
illegal, but I would definitely
put one of these in my large zoo one day.
- We're all pals, like, let's
go hang out and eat leaves.
Salad, anyone?
- You're my friend now.
- It's just nature happening
on the table (laughs).
And they're eatin' leaves.
It's the cutest thing I've ever seen.